Speaking of moms, one of the biggest missions on our shows
is to keep moms feeling connected
and supported and heard, especially this year.
My goodness.
And you know, sometimes we just think,
how do we even take a break when you need it most?
And as a parent, you put yourself last.
It's just a fact.
And so we think about that here.
And when a woman named Melissa reached out to us
about her friend, Angela,
we knew that we wanted to team up to surprise her
in a thing we like to call Mom's Time-out.
Hey, Drew, I wanna nominate my girlfriend, Angela.
She had cancer three or four years ago.
And then, like six months later,
I was diagnosed with cancer as well.
So we were both gone through breast cancer.
She was my rock.
She would come over and bring me cards
and leave little gifts on my doorstep.
Angela lost her husband about nine years ago.
And she had a four-year-old daughter
that she had to take care of.
Whenever you see her, she just has that smile like that.
Not only is she a single mother,
but she decided to foster kids herself.
That's just the kind of person she is.
And she'll go to our local restaurants and pick up soup
or pick up whatever food that they have.
And she delivers them all over.
I mean, this girl is, she's crazy. (laughs)
I don't know where she finds the time to do that,
but it's so much a part of who she is.
When I say Angela, I think of all the compassionate things
that she does for other people.
And she never asked for anything for herself ever.
She always puts people first,
and I think that is the most important thing.
(audience applauding)
Hi, Angela.
I am so excited to meet you.
How do you give back when you're being this example
of such an amazing person?
There's a variety of ways that I do give back.
Me and a partner run a Christmas program
to where we help families in need,
make sure that they do not have,
that they aren't forgotten on Christmas.
It's called Community Santa Project.
I also help with my friends.
Oh yes, there's the soup.
And Soup for Soul is one of the local restaurants.
Donated soup to us, and we were able to get it to shelters,
as well as to local families in need.
We also help with a local children's cancer organization
called Cancer Kiss my Cooley,
who was started by my best friends
after they lost their six-year-old to a brain tumor.
So I have my spread out a little bit,
but just enough to give me balance while raising Kayla.
Well, I would be honored if I could participate
in your Christmas program with my daughters,
because I'm always looking to find the road
to all the examples out there,
especially during the holidays.
It's such a time where we're so aware
of how important it is to take care of each other.
So we would love to put that on our website,
all of your missions on our website,
and help raise as much awareness and funds as we can.
And you've been through so much
and lived such an extraordinary life.
A couple examples is surviving cancer,
surviving the loss of a husband.
Yes I did.
And yet being able to be someone who really gives back
to their community through all of that.
May I ask how do you be the kind of person that you are?
I started out young.
My parents were very giving and loving people.
And I was raised that way.
I want to be the best parent I can for my child,
and the way to do that is by leading by example.
When I was pregnant with Olive, my first child,
I was scared of that notion, leading by example,
because my example was a very Bohemian self-sufficient life,
and I heard this story on none other than Oprah Radio.
And Oprah said, "Gayle, Gayle, tell that story."
And she's like, "I don't know why
you love this story so much."
And she's like, "Just tell it, just tell it."
And she's like, "I went and took my son Will to college,
and I noticed his dorm room fridge was empty.
And so I took him to the local store to get a few things,
and we noticed a traffic cop.
It was like the heat, summer.
He was out there sweating, and we went in to get stuff,
and I came back and I saw him and I went back in.
I got a case of water and I brought it to him.
Why? Why do you love this story so much?"
And Oprah said, "Because in that moment,
you taught your son what kind of human being to be."
And it gave me the faith I needed,
as a mom with a baby in my belly,
that examples were true and that they do work.
But never in a million years
can you really hold someone up higher than you.
Thank you, Drew. Thank you.
Angela, I have a confession actually.
Your best friend, Melissa, actually reached out to me,
and she's here with us today.
Hi Melissa.
(audience cheering)
Hi, guys.
Hi, Angie!
Hi, Melissa.
Melissa, did you want to tell Angela something today?
Oh god, I'm gonna start crying.
You know how much you mean to me
and everything that you have gone through.
And you're always putting everybody first.
When I was diagnosed, you were first person to call me
and like, "What do you need?
I'm there for you."
That meant a lot, obviously,
because you knew what I was going through,
going through it yourself.
Just watching you, oh, okay, I'm gonna start crying.
You mean so much to me.
And I hope that you know that.
I do.
Sorry I'm emotional.
It is such a beautiful thing.
Really I'm just here to say,
we wanted to celebrate all the amazing work
that you have done for your community.
And we'd love to treat you
to an all-expense-paid vacation to Fiji for two.
I hope that would be okay.
Oh my goodness, that would be wonderful.
Okay, great.
And when it's safe to travel again,
we're gonna send you and a guest
to Yasawa Island Resort and Spa, Fiji,
which is tucked away off the coast of Fiji's main island,
and they offer the ultimate in all-inclusive luxury.
And you'll be arriving courtesy
of the national airline of Fiji, Fiji Airways.
And by the way, those airlines are like having
a trip in itself.
And so from when the car picks you up
to the very last minute of your vacation,
we're just gonna take care of the whole thing
and make sure it is nearly as perfect as you are.
So this is our way of saying thank you again
for being an example
and the exceptional person that you are.
This is a well-deserved Mom's Time-out.
Oh, that's so amazing. Thank you so much, Drew.
Thank you, Angela and Melissa.
Thanks for letting me hang out with you guys.
(upbeat music)